if you thought king viserys talking to a
12 year old was bad then honey you've
got a big storm coming episode 4 of
house of the dragon is here with all the
heartwarming family drama we've come to
expect
i'm sorry what is that a tea princess
this video is a non-spoiler deep dive
into the episode lore and connections to
game of thrones so join me in my pillow
house and make sure to like and
subscribe this one's gonna get weird we
open on that valerian steel necklace
rhaenyra was gifted from prince damon in
episode 1. not only does this act as
foreshadowing for what's to come but i
think it's pretty telling that rhaenyra
has all these suitors lined up for her
yet she insists on holding an object
given to her by her uncle although never
explicitly stated we are likely at
storm's end the seat of house baratheon
notice the circular shape of the room
which may be the mass of drum tower
described in fire and blood it is said
that the castle is protected by spells
woven into the very walls to prevent
magic from passing through it next to
the princess is bormond baratheon who
you'll remember asked for rainis's favor
at the tournament in episode 1 and who
also swore allegiance to the king and
rhaenyra as heir rhaenyra's father king
viserys set up a grand tour spanning
several months which will take the
princess across the realm in search of a
suitable husband last episode the king
told her that she must marry but gave
her the option of choosing this man
herself but as we'll find out it seems
no one has caught her eye lining up like
sheep to the slaughter are several
houses we can see house tully swann who
we heard last episode lost lady joanna
in the step zones and sold to a pillow
house house frey we remember those guys
mud and strong we met two new members of
house strong last episode harwan and
lloris with their father being the
current master of laws on the small
council making his case as the
princess's future casanova is a fossil
by the name of lord dondarian this is
particularly interesting because sir
kristen cole's father serves under this
house you may recall the dondarian line
from game of thrones where we met lord
barrick dondarrion and his flaming sword
when he's not having to quench his
thirst with some metamucil lord
dundarian recounts that rhaenyra's
great-grandmother queen alisene once
remarked that the marches where the seed
of dundarian is located were beautiful
queen alisan was the wife of king
jiharis who we saw briefly in episode 1.
and honestly rhaenyra is kind of a royal
[ __ ] making a fool of dundarian in
front of all the other lords even borman
turns turn is like yo you might want to
turn that down i'm pretty sure lord
dondarrion will remember this moment
should the princess's claims to
secession ever be questioned as they say
a lord spurned is a lord burned i just
made that up i apologize and from one
end of the age spectrum we come to the
other a boy from house blackwood slides
into rhaenyra's dms extolling the size
of his house's army and that by marrying
him she'd be marrying someone with the
blood of the first men flowing through
his veins the first men were considered
the first of three major ethnic groups
of human that set foot in westeros the
other being the rhoynar and andals this
kid's great-great-grandfather helped
aegon the conqueror in his quest to
conquer westeros aid which this emile
hirsch looking character makes fun of
this is a member of house bracken over
at the riverlands if we look at our map
you can see stonehedge where house
bracken makes its home is right near
raventree hall where house blackwood is
located so it's very likely there is
some history between these two houses
that goes beyond these minor jokes the
two actually end up fighting and in the
melee rhaenyra makes her escape they are
expected in a bitter bridge in three
days time but rhaenyra wants to go home
cutting her grand tour to find a husband
by two whole months something that her
father won't be too pleased about note
to self this is not why you pick on the
little guy off the coast of king's
landing rhinera prepares for her arrival
she's rejected more suitors than a
season of the bachelorette hot off his
victory at the stepstones damon swoops
in on caraxas knocking rhaenyra over
even though her noggin gets a floggin
she can't help but be mesmerized by her
uncle an uncle she wouldn't have seen
for several years this is gonna be more
awkward than my family's thanksgiving in
the realm's biggest dick swinging
contest in decades viserys prepares to
meet his brother donning his crown and
valerian steel broadsword blackfyre
reneira is the only one to follow
alongside him through the crowd as he
makes his entrance which i thought was
pretty interesting not to be outdone
daemon 2 has a crown one that looks to
be made by my niece during craft time
but damon also brings with him
craigastrahar's hammer the one he used
to nail his victims along the beach and
in a total badass move damon tells his
brother to add it to his chair add it to
the chair
damon has not come to challenge his
brother but to offer his crown and the
stepstones to which he was made king by
lord corliss these lands never
officially belong to daemon they were
always the crowns so this is largely
symbolic of damon trying to mend the
relationship between he and his brother
after all winning the stepstones was
never really about the land but to prove
that he could do this without the help
of his brother a particular note are
these cutaways to otto who watches the
scene intently daemon is a chaotic force
at king's landing and one could even
argue that if it weren't for him coming
back otto would still be hand of the
king so it's in otto's best interest
that the king and his brother remain
apart absent is lord coreless valerian
still pouting over the fact that king
didn't marry his 12 year old daughter
corliss ii got what he wanted out of the
stepstones secure trade routes through
the narrow sea upon which his fortune
was built the scene ends with the two
brothers hugging in front of the court
with the king telling him in front of
everyone that the realm owes him a great
debt for damon this is all he's ever
wanted to be loved and at his brother's
side and oh that will be short lived
damon's celebration is taken outside
where viserys talks about how their
mother always liked damon moore he was a
great warrior while viserys was one to
abide by rules and tradition and what
family reunion isn't without its awkward
banter when alison suggests damon view
the new tapestries from novos and kohor
two of the nine free cities on the
continent of essos it really shows how
little alison knows about her
brother-in-law in fact in the books
damon didn't even attend their wedding
speaking of allison we'll see that she's
no longer pregnant as she was last
episode having already given birth to
her second child helena rhaenyra excuses
herself to sit alone just like me at
lunch in high school allison or should i
say her stepmom has come to see how her
tour went it must be nice to have all
the men of the realm fawning over her
but for renera it's all a farce all
she's wanted for is her name and
valerian blood with rhaenyra stating
that it's not romantic to be confined to
a castle squeezing out heirs something
she soon realizes is exactly what alison
is going through the two realize they
aren't too different after all both feel
like their lives are out of their hands
and both have few friends they both miss
each other and it seems like this is the
first step toward them reconciling
sometime later after the party is
cleared out rhaenyra talks to her uncle
for the first time since their
precarious meeting at dragonstone some
years ago damon has come back to enjoy
the comforts of home which likely
include frequenting the various brothels
at king's landing his war in the steps
zone seemed to have put an end at the
prospects of marriage with massaria who
we'll see again in a little bit in
daemon rhaenyra finds someone to vent to
she laments being sold off to whichever
lord has the biggest castle to which
damon replies there are worse things to
be sold for this might be a slight jab
at his own wife raya royce who he was
married off to he had no say in this
marriage an arrangement which was put
together by his grandmother now he calls
his wife the bronze [ __ ] named after
the ancient bronze armor their royce
family are known for for damon marriage
is but a political tool once married he
can go off and fool around with anyone
he so desires but for women it's a death
sentence rhaenyra won't subject herself
to the same fate as her mother who in an
effort to produce a male conceived so
many times that it killed her but
rhaenyra can't go on living in fear or
else she'll forsake the best parts of
living it's essentially daemon setting
her up to be even more rebellious
something that we'll definitely see
later on in the episode the small
council has convened and you'll notice
two new additions rhaenyra has a seat at
the table it looks like she's no longer
the cupbearer we also see tylan
lannister has taken over corliss's seat
as master of ships speaking of corliss
there is some concerning news otto was
sent word from old town that lord
corless plans to marry lena off to a sea
lord of braavos the wealthiest and most
powerful of the free cities if this were
to occur the targaryens would need to
enter into their own marriage pact to
counter this potential threat this will
undoubtedly put even more pressure on
rhaenyra to wed as night descends upon
the red keep the servants of the castle
make their nightly rounds sir kristin
stands guard outside ranira's chambers
but as the princess adventures inside
she notices a strange bang filled with
boys clothes and a note if i ever found
that in my room i'd be checking behind
the drapes to make sure the subway guy
wasn't around written in high valerian
is a drawing of a secret passageway the
red keep was known to have several of
these and i guess we'll just have to buy
into the fact that rhaenyra has likely
been in this room for her whole life and
never noticed this giant secret door
that leads to the cellars where belarian
skull resides damon has been waiting
he's also disguised as they descend the
debaucherous street of silk known for
its pleasure houses and street
performers who don't care if they send
your eyebrows off this is my favorite
dude you wish to know your death child
she's highly rated on yelp juxtaposing
this adventurous night out is queen
alicent with her legion covered husband
in the bath i'd hate to be the servant
who has to clean that out it really
looks like his mysterious illness has
progressed although this was seen last
episode he has lost at least two of his
fingers back with whom damon calls the
small folk basically westeros's version
of peasants or the common people
rhaenyra watches a play about the royal
secession this will have been one of the
first times she's been exposed to the
harsh realities of the outside world
watching as their commoners jest and boo
her the whole sequence reminded me of
that scene in game of thrones where arya
watches a play about king joffrey's
death that occurred in braavos and at
least women were allowed to act in it
whereas the play renera watches all the
female roles are played by men which is
something that was actually done in
shakespearean times damon is kind of
enjoying watching her niece take this in
she's been in her own protective bubble
her entire life and if she is to be the
queen knowing the pulse of the common
folk is a trait that would surely come
in handy he tells her that many of the
small folk believe a male should be king
to which she retorts their wants are of
no consequence if this is how she really
thinks what will this say about how
she'll rule renewal openly takes food
off a street seller's tray not knowing
that you're to pay them beforehand her
whole life she's never had to pay for
anything she runs off with damon in
pursuit bumping into a member of the
city watch who recognizes her as the
princess he also sees that she's with
damon and these two likely are buds
considering damon used to be commander
of the city guard and even had a loyal
contingent of them when he took
dragonstone alison is called to the
king's chambers to perform her royal
duty of pleasing that booty it's a stark
contrast to rhaenyra's escapades and
paints a pretty grim picture that even
though the queen is one of the most
powerful people in the realm she is also
a prisoner damon takes rhaenyra to any
normal place you'd take your niece a
brothel where he states this is a place
where people come to take what they want
he's just full of great advice as the
two make their way deeper into the den
he takes off her disguise surely he
realizes people will notice the
well-known prince and the princess but
there's two things at play here one he's
insanely drunk and deep down i don't
think he really cares remember that he
just told his niece to take whatever the
hell she wants the two end up making out
but when things are about to take the
path of no return damon storms off
leaving rhaenyra all alone like me on
prom night outside the brothel a little
boy spy takes note of rhaenyra's
presence this boy works for a woman
named the white worm who we'll find out
is massaria spies are common all around
king's landing and beyond both varys and
peter baelish use spies for their own
political gain so it seems massaria 2 is
using this later informing otto
hightower of the princesses escapades
rainer returns to the front door of her
chambers surprising sir kristen who was
tasked with protecting her she's this
young girl who has just taken on this
extremely sexual experience and blue
bald so it's no wonder when she gets
home and there's this hunky night she's
been fawning over for years standing
right there that she makes her move
damon told her after all to take what
she wants at first kristen is like
this is a
risky business but ultimately he
succumbs and she loses her virginity
this is also a huge breach of his oath
as a kingsguard he is to act respectably
and not engage in sexual affairs let
alone with the woman you're sworn to
protect the book offers differing
accounts on what happened this fateful
evening one is from septon eustis who
writes that sir eric cargill of the
kingsguard caught damon and the princess
in bed together with rhaenyra pleading
to her father that she was in love with
her uncle and that they should leave and
marry the other is more in line with
what occurs in the show with some minor
differences in this scenario damon finds
out that raniere is in love with sir
kristen and takes her to the street of
silk to learn about lovemaking and then
ranira comes back offering her virginity
to sir kristen but in the book version
he's horrified by her proposition and
declines i definitely like the way the
show handled this because it leaves room
for so much spicy drama in the episodes
to come with an engagement on the way
will sir kristen and rainier's love
affair continue or will one of them put
a stop to it at some sort of inn
slightly more luxurious than a motel 6
massaria takes care of the hungover
daemon here we see her collecting
payment from the boy who divulged those
scandalous rumors to otto hightower
maybe this is part revenge for what he
did to her on dragonstone either way she
is not happy with him it also makes me
wonder how long have messaria and otto
been working together the king awakens
to the shocking rumor that her daughter
and brother were caught in a pleasure
house quote coupling whatever that means
an alison creeps off to the side like i
can't believe my [ __ ] ears the king's
first instinct is that this is all a lie
and he wants the eyes cut out of whoever
created such a salacious rumor but otto
won't divulge his source saying this
person has never led him astray one
little detail which i just absolutely
love is how much more massive viserys's
model of the valerian city has gotten
since we saw it in episode 1 just check
out the difference the king then accuses
otto of besmirching his daughter's
reputation and otto would have motive to
do so even though the king has given
birth to a male son the son of a
hightower rhaenyra is still the king's
chosen heir and if you thought your
morning afters were awkward just take a
look at sir kristen who's come to escort
the princess to the queen having heard
the allegations against her alison has
come to ask ranira of the truth she
knows the targaryens have weird customs
but hooking up with your own uncle
behind everyone's back i could not
believe my ears rhaenyra fires back
saying that to question her virtue is an
act of treason demanding to know who
made such vile accusations but when
ronira finds out they're merely rumors
that otto heard rhaenyra swears on her
mother's memory that her uncle never
touched her which is of course a
complete lie rhaenyra also doesn't bring
up the fact that she hooked up with sir
kristen as alison points out if the
lords of the land were to find out she
had been sullied it would ruin
everything damon arrives back at the
keep looking like me when i come home
after the bar he's taken by sir harold
westerling and the kingsguard to be
brought before his brother to answer for
these rumors and in a complete twist not
only does he say they are true but that
he went all the way with his niece but
why would he lie about this later in a
conversation between the king and
allison allison claims he did this
because it reduces the king it makes him
look bad but we know that damon
ultimately loves his brother so i
believe this tactic was more
self-motivated he wants rhaenyra and
even asks his brother to wed them if he
were to wed rhaenyra he'd become king
consort upon her ascension a match like
this is not uncommon in the targaryen
family their parents after all were
brother and sister the king however sees
past this stating that it's not his
daughter damon lust4 but the throne
their reconciliation short-lived he
orders that damon never show his face
around him again alison informs the king
of her talk with rhaenyra in which he
states the princess remains a maiden so
that was a [ __ ] lie sir kristen leads
rhaenyra to her father who not ominous
at all heats up the cat's pod dagger he
tells her that before aegon the
conqueror's death the last of the
valerian pyromancers hid his prophecy on
the blade itself only visible at extreme
temperatures this responsibility of
handing down the conqueror's dream the
song of ice and fire is larger than
everything even the throne kingdom and
herself viserys notes that if jiharis
were king he would have disinherited
rhaenyra even if the rumors turned out
to be false that's because as viserys
says the truth does not matter only
perception it's basically the king's way
of saying the only thing that matters is
the court of public opinion however it
will be interesting next episode if the
king is able to quash these rumors or if
they'll spread if rhaenyra were a man
she could have a dozen bastards and see
whomever she liked but as her father
reminds her she's not a man it's not
fair but forget it jake it's chyna i
mean king's landing the king is fed up
and tells her her courtship is at an end
she is to marry layner valerian and
unite the two most powerful houses in
the realm but what is the king to do
about the quote a vulture who perches on
his throne otto hightower he was the one
who spied on the princess and tried to
disgrace her how can such a man who is
so self-interested properly advised the
king rhaenyra says she will do her duty
as heir and marry lanor if the king does
his duty and cans the hand becerras
brings in otto to the small council
chambers and tells him a story about how
otto became hand when jaehaerus was king
his hand was his son balon or viserys's
father in the book baylon was hand for
two years before he died however the
show version states that five days after
a hunting trip celebrating him being
named hand he fell gravely ill this is
odd because balin was considered quite
strong and healthy and just who happens
to be named hand after baylon's demise
otto hightower going from common lore to
the second most powerful man in the
realm it's an insinuation that otto may
have been involved in the prince's death
combine this with the very calculated
move to put his daughter near the king
during his time of mourning a clear
attempt to make her queen viserys knows
otto has overstepped his bounds and can
no longer be trusted the king removes
otto's pin tells him the realm owes him
a great debt and removes him from his
post in the book he is also removed as
hand but more so because he kept
hounding viserys to declare alison's son
heir to the throne instead of rhaenyra
this leaves an opening spot for hand of
the king in the book we know who this
goes to but if i told you that would be
breaking the law hint hint if you want
spoilers check out my next episode
trailer videos which usually come out
within 24 hours of these breakdowns our
final heartwarming scene of the episode
occurs when our beloved grand maester
melos arrives with some special tea for
rhaenyra tea that would rid her of any
unwanted consequences of course we don't
actually know if rhaenyra is pregnant
it's only been a day so this is a
preventative measure should she be with
child because this tea was sent on the
king's orders it also shows how much
distrust he has towards his daughter now
if you want to find out what happens
next episode and the fallout from all
these rumors be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss my episode 5 preview video
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt until
next time remember
this is a
risky business